welcome back well on this show last
month Sam Jima announced his intention
to stand for the Conservative Party
leadership in the end he failed to get
enough nominations but pro-eu MPs like
him could have a big role to play when
the next prime minister inherits two
resumes wafer-thin
majority well Sam Jima joins us now
thank you for being on the program
morning so who you can debate for them
I'm not declaring so far I have come on
it I am NOT declaring I didn't declare
during the MP rounds and I'm not going
to declare during this round and there
is a simple reason for that which is
once you declaring you're seen as part
of a camp it's very difficult to
actually come out and comment on what is
going on without it being seen as
representing someone else obviously I
want to be free to comment on the big
issues that we face and for that reason
I don't see it necessary to declare who
I'll be voting for but I do have a vote
in five four two votes and I I would use
it okay well in that case if you are
this you know unbiased commentator on
the race what do you make a delivery job
either so what do you what do you make
of the leadership race so far then the
campaign I think it's been disappointing
and disappointing because the reason why
the vacancy exists is to resolve how we
go forward and brexit and I don't think
we've made any progress on that during
the course of this contest well some
with the opposite view for me you might
not think that they might think that
actually we have made a promise so that
you know we're going to get out by the
end of October we're going to get out by
the end of October but a government that
has got a working majority of three and
a new prime minister that hasn't faced
the electorate I think will struggle in
practice to take the UK out of the EU
without a deal when a significant
majority of the population is also
against that option at the end of
October we face two options we either
revoke or we leave without a deal and my
view is both options are extreme and
there is no mandate for either option
and so for a new prime minister to talk
either way without going back to the
people would be impossible that is why I
stood on platform of a referendum
because I wanted what I desperately want
one but we need a way to break the
impasse in a general election for the
Conservative Party at this stage would
be some of tomorrow so if if we get to
the end of October and the prime
minister who
is going to try and take the UK out the
EU without a deal will you try and stop
me
I have always voted against No Deal and
I will continue to do so and not just me
I think there are a lot of MPs on the
conservative side how many do you think
and cross Anna Collins well I think
there is a significant number and that
will vote that would use legislative
options to do two things I mean it's
that like less than 10 is that more like
30 I mean about 30 30 plus but what
we'll be looking to do is stop the new
prime minister from perogy in Parliament
in order to deliver a deal but also
create options for the new prime
minister so that new deal is not the
only option we face on the 31st of
October so how are you do that then well
there are there are a number of our
legislative mechanisms being looked at
at the moment and we will sort of come
to them when we do I wouldn't want sort
of announced them before you know they
may be self tested as viable but there
is a real concern and the real concern
here is not about levers or Romania's
the real concern here is that this is
not in the interest of our country now
in the last week you asked me what do I
think of the contest we've had a lot of
commentary on brexit and how we're going
to receive a brexit boost by cutting
this tax and cutting that tax actually
what all of this is about is Stephen of
economic mayhem now in a scenario where
you sort of break of your legs and get
on crutches and say that is a dividend
it's not a mobility dividend it's not
any different you know we already hurt
in the economy I think that is something
that most people are concerned about the
Union is also very important is een for
example Boris Johnson said he'll be
Minister for the Union but when you
reflect on it the imposing on the
Singlish Tories imposing on the Scots
the policy the least like and that
causes them harm is their most likely
way for us to have a second successful
Scottish independence referendum so no
deal could break up the country then
also harm our economy so for that reason
there are a lot of MPs and it's not
about leave remain who think that the
truly patriotic thing to do is not to
play to Nigel Farage's tune but to find
a better way for you
talking about some important issues
there but isn't democracy also important
the majority of people in the UK voted
to leave the European Union I mean that
is why we are here and if they feel that
MPs are effectively trying to ignore
them then that's going to be also mayhem
isn't it that's oh that's a complete
fallacy in the debate people voted to
leave the EU but people were told that
there will be a deal they leave campaign
to people that might be a deal if
someone is beta denied your Farraj and
those people didn't want that to you
right they say they don't want the deal
that's on the table but people were told
during a referendum campaign that there
will be a deal people were told in our
manifesto that there will be a deal
the anti-democratic thing to do would be
having promised people that there will
be a deal and they all have the exact
same benefits to take the EU the UK out
of the EU without a deal where people's
jobs suffer that is the undemocratic
thing to do in this situation nobody
voted to leave without a deal you were
clearly very worried about the idea of
leaving without a deal now early on the
programme Labour's Barry Gardner said
that Labour will hold a confidence
motion in the government when they fail
that there's enough support from the
conservative side can you rule out ever
voting against a Conservative government
in a confidence motion I've been very
explicit about that's not something I
intend to do you know I think it's the
nuclear option I don't want to go there
I know some that are considering it but
I wouldn't go there but I believe that
the measures come out yes but the other
measures we are looking at will be
sensible and will be pragmatic and will
create space for the new prime minister
to move away from what they think they
have to say in an election campaign for
160,000 members I mean you and governor
in the interests of the country you're
clearly talking to some of the MPs who
as you say potentially considering the
conference motion option do you think
there's enough that it might pass I
can't comment for others but but I think
that for the future of the many people
who think going leaving without a deal
and play to Nigel Farage's tune is a
good thing I think that is the way to
save the Conservative Party and I think
that is also wrong because the
Conservative Party that breaks up the
union a Conservative Party that damages
the economy but a Conservative Party
that becomes the governing arm of the
brexit party will very quickly
run out of voters and wouldn't be in
government very long would you say it's
an MP if you felt that was the case
oh yes I'm going to fight for what is
real conservatism and real conservative
is pragmatic real conservatism
is not worried about thinking again a
real conservatism above all puts the
country first and I think that is what I
in a number of my colleagues who are
concerned about New Deal will be
fighting for over the next few weeks and
months we want to rediscover what is may
the conservative party there was
successful Democratic Party in the world
is that we are pragmatic we're
pro-business and also we have been
instrumental to this 300 years
successful Union that our country us
that's what I'll be fighting for okay
Sam Chima thank you very much for coming
on the program this morning